sí
[Música]
hola a todos y bienvenidos a esta nueva
emisión de los observadores en france24
esta semana iremos en yamena en la
capital de chad donde nuestro observador
socorre a los niños de la calle para
intentar que vuelvan con sus familias o
hacerse cargo de ellos con su
organización luego veremos la noticia
falsa de la semana sobre el vídeo de una
concentración ciclista en irlanda que
dio lugar a algunas especulaciones
[Música]
ayudar a los niños de la calle
invitándolos a bailar es la original
iniciativa del bailarín profesional
chadiano eleva a bogut y funciona en 5
años su organización tachado stars ha
podido rescatar a 600 niños de las
calles de la capital en yamena como lo
explica nuestro observador quien también
vivió en la calle durante su infancia
utilizamos la danza como carnada y en
primer lugar intervenimos con urgencia
para encontrar a sus niños
porque los consideramos víctimas que ya
no tienen la fuerza ni la voluntad de
acudir a las instituciones públicas
ordinarias del drop con mí
y los espectáculos que hacemos en la
calle también son una forma de motivar a
estos niños recaudamos dinero y luego
también les damos comida
[Aplausos]
y pensamos que sería útil tener un
centro y este centro permite acoger a
estos niños
hoy nos ocupamos de 65 niños y jóvenes
hay 48 matriculados en la escuela desde
primaria hasta el último curso también
hay 15 que están en formación
profesional como mecánica soldadura
carpintería
hay quienes aspiran hoy a ser bailarines
profesionales son 10
yo personalmente con mi equipo los
entreno para que puedan abrirse camino
en la danza el día de mañana para
nosotros la calle nunca ha dado luz a un
niño y todos estos niños vienen de un
hogar de una familia
por eso es muy importante que primero
nos pongamos en contacto con los padres
y hagamos esta mediación familiar la
pérdida de los padres la pérdida de la
autoridad la falta de afecto de los
padres la pobreza la separación de los
padres son todos estos problemas los que
agrupan estos niños que acaban en la
calle
también hemos podido identificar a niños
de nigeria tras los ataques de boko
haram también hay niños de la república
centroafricana que hemos podido
identificar y otros de cambio
común para financiarse a la organización
de nuestro observador utiliza los
honorarios de los espectáculos
realizados con los jóvenes pero también
el dinero recaudado durante las giras de
albada bogut que ha bailado en ciudades
como parís y nueva york la chava star
también recibe donaciones si desean
ayudarles vayan a su página de facebook
o pónganse en contacto con nuestra
redacción
[Música]
un vídeo de un grupo de ciclistas en
dublín se hizo viral recientemente
algunos grupos identitarios xenófobos
estaban seguros de que mostraba una
pandilla anti musulmana y africana esto
no es cierto y nuestro reportero tristán
were mister nos explica el porqué de
esta noticia falsa
miénteme
al parecer bandas de inmigrantes
africanos musulmanes en irlanda se están
peleando con adolescentes irlandeses lo
que provocó la muerte de un chico
irlandés los adolescentes forman una
banda y patrullan muchos por la calle el
vídeo llega a más de 80 mil visitas en
telegram incluyendo visitas de grupos
identitarios y de supremacía blanca
muestra un grupo de ciclistas
recorriendo un parque en primer lugar
verifiquemos que el vídeo haya sido
grabado en irlanda
el obelisco se puede encontrar
fácilmente en las imágenes satelitales
corresponde al monumento de wellington
situado en el parque fénix de dublín una
patrulla de policía también estuvo
presente nos pusimos en contacto con la
policía de lulín esto es lo que dijeron
un gran grupo de jóvenes se reunió en
bicicleta en la zona de listo bold de
dublín el viernes 29 de enero alrededor
de las 16 horas la policía estaba
presente y vigiló el avance del grupo
hacia el parque félix no se produjeron
incidentes ni detenciones el grupo se
dispersó pacíficamente para conocer las
razones de esta concentración busquemos
el nombre de este barrio en un buscador
sea contamos las fechas de este
resultado digamos del 25 al 29 de enero
encontramos artículos de prensa sobre
una noticia del 26 de enero la muerte de
georgetown una joven promesa del fútbol
irlandés de 16 años esto es lo que
sabemos de las circunstancias de su
muerte según la policía del intento de
robo la bicicleta de un repartidor de
delivery se salió de control
josh intervino para detener la disputa
pero fue apuñalado que tiene que ver
este evento con el vídeo al buscar en
tick tock con el hashtag georgetown
podemos encontrar imágenes de una
conmemoración organizada al día
siguiente de su funeral
vemos adolescentes reunidos en el lugar
del asesinato atraviesan dublín en
bicicleta algunos de ellos tienen una
camiseta blanca con la foto
las mismas del vídeo viral
según los periodistas locales los
adolescentes acudieron en masa
frustrados por no poder asistir al
funeral debido a las restricciones
sanitarias nos pusimos en contacto con
uno de los participantes nos confirmó
que el grupo inició al recorrido en
bicicleta desde el barrio donde vivía
george y se dirigió al lugar del
asesinato pasando por el parque podemos
verlos en estas imágenes en el monumento
a wellington pero porque el pie de foto
del vídeo menciona a los migrantes los
repartidores de el hielo en dublín a
menudo de origen extranjero suelen ser
víctimas de agresiones a veces racistas
sin embargo en este vídeo no hay racismo
ni violencia según los participantes
contactados aunque algunas personas
afirmaron querer vengar la muerte de su
amigo a nadie se le habría ocurrido
actuar
en conclusión este vídeo no muestra ni
pandillas ni patrullas sino adolescentes
conmemorando la muerte de su amigo
puede encontrar todas nuestras
verificaciones en nuestro sitio web o en
la sección info intouch
por correo electrónico whatsapp facebook
y si quiere convertirse en nuestros
observadores de france 24 no dude en
enviarnos sus imágenes aficionados hasta
pronto
ah